it's the point about the house of
commons in one sense is is that it was
rebuilt when the commons burned down uh
in
1834 at the height of our victorian
imperial power and it was built to
impress foreigners and it built with
this extraordinary high standards but
it's a
19th century building um for the 21st
century with all the all the kind of
quirks oddities pageantry of of the 19th
century still there and some of the
other conventions that go back another
500 years beyond that so it's a strange
place to to
be
running as a legislator in in in the
21st century martha i just want to pick
up what michael was saying there he's
talking about the building and the
tradition the pomp and ceremony i mean a
lot of people say that's british culture
it's what people look to the uk for and
quite enjoy but is there a way that you
can marry that with a more modern form
of politics particularly our young
stand-up be counters are talking about
there and the way that mps behave when
they're debating important issues
yes i i don't think so i mean
it's it's quite similar to
law in some ways you've got the pageant
trend ceremony there and that works
quite well because you want some
distance between the people who you're
judging and the judges
but it's quite at odds with the with
with the job of being an mp where you're
trying to engage the public and be and
in a very direct way i mean why tweet
and why uh tell people how much you like
the arctic monkeys or you know candy
crush saga if you're then going to uh
going to work and there's a sword peg in
the collect room i mean it's it's i
think i think there's there's something
that needs to be resolved there what
about prime minister's questions
which again
you know it is fashionable john burko
says he doesn't like the way people
behave those young stand-up encounters
said they didn't didn't like it
on the other hand you know you can only
look at twitter every week there's a lot
of visceral partisanship about it is it
now
becoming more of a liability than an
asset do you think well it's interesting
that
david cameron says you know that uh
every other leader around the world uh
is are very surprised that that every
week he goes into
prime minister's question and mps have a
chance to ask
the head of the government uh so it is
it is an important thing in a democracy
to have that with the prime minister
going in every on the other hand the way
it is carried out now as we showed in
the film that that um a number of tory
mps or every tory mp gets sent an email
with with helpful questions
yes
exactly um uh with helpful questions to
brandon that's not what it should be nor
should it be the kind of punch and duty
that it it has become and every leader
of the opposition every prime minister
has always said i want to end punching
duty politics and it lasts for about
half an hour and then they go back to it
that's their default setting and so you
have often
questions which are stooge questions and
answers which are stooge answers in that
they're pre-digested sound bites fed to
the prime minister or the leader of the
opposition by their spin doctors if he
asks this you ask you you say this and
people get turned off by that
it's quite interesting isn't it because
there are programs on television i mean
we do them here on sky news where we
have mps on debating the issues of the
day and that gets more viewers than pmqs
may do so is it not their responsibility
that's their prime time if you like
that's their showcase to to put across
what they want to say without
journalists like us uh testing them too
much should they not revamp it and make
it more accessible perhaps they should
but i think the reason it's in gym so
long is actually punching gd politics is
quite fun to watch
quite rowdy i actually find that much
more engaging they have much greater
viewing figures than other parliamentary
programs um i think the trouble with
this particular punch and judy show is
that it's an eaton brand punching judy
show it's a public school boy it's a
sort of old boys club type of rowdiness
there's braying there's kind of the
honorable gentleman there's the older
them and that's what turns people off i
think it needs to be i think politicians
female politicians are perfectly able to
handle themselves in a rowdy debate um
it's just it's just that particular kind
of male heckling kind of eateny vibe
which is which is which is i mean and
your camera angles and shows is actually
if you're there even rougher than it
looks on the normal television with that
well yes i mean the normal television
the parliamentary uh television there
are many restrictions in what you can
show and it's also
high mounted cameras where we were on
the floor of the house so you could see
the white i mean laura peter told me
that they can't actually hear what's
being said until they go and the prime
minister said the same to me that he
often couldn't hear the question but he
answered what he believed that what from
what he knew of the mps standing up
the question was likely to be if it was
an opposition mp and martha what would
be the main things that you would like
to modernize about parliament and we saw
our stand-up be counters raising quite a
few issues including you know equality
and transparency what do you think would
be the key things you'd modernize
um well i think in general though there
is very good places to start um i like
the idea of electronic voting i think
there's a there's a sort of there's a
late night a lot of late night voting
that goes on in the house of commons i
mean you do say that sorry to interrupt
but um the mps themselves say the thing
about voting in person and going through
the lobbies is is that they do get a
chance say to to beard a minister and
they can do more business in 10 minutes
in the division lobbies than than they
uh have the chance to do over the course
of a week because they can surely make
the
devices only work when you're in the
house of commons amongst your peers but
in fact queuing for voting uh to vote
takes 15 minutes each vote
you said they've got electronic voting
in the house of representatives it takes
just as long so
i don't know
thank you very much indeed